okay thank you Clara I was talking to
Clara that's let's try and keep her time
because the best part which is the panel
discussion we all do want to have an
hour of panel discussions so let's start
with our first paper in the section
trans mexico lindo que de do which is
Mexican scenes representations of Mexico
City in the new cinema and my ear Moreno
is going to give the speech good
afternoon and thank you Clara for
inviting me we are going to be seeing a
lot of me today I'm sorry good afternoon
again and I will be presenting two
papers i'm sorry but i am the co-author
of this one and all the only one here to
present so this is called Mexican
science representations of mexico city
in the new cinema
so Mexico has sorry Mexico has one of
the most prolific and critically
acclaimed film industries in the world
films such as amores perros el crimen
del padre amaro I mean tu mama tambien
half capture and internationally
imagination and rain gained Mexico's
reputation for quality script and
production values Mexican films and
directors have won numerous awards and
be nominated the nominations for in
short leads while actors such as Castle
maahiya can guide garcia bernal have
become regulars at international
festivals and on the red carpet the
Senate was rich in 2007 when Mexican
film projects received 16 Oscar
nominations leading Mexicans directors
have worked on films recognized and new
as not Mexican or global productions
such as a general del Toro but labyrinth
and Hellboy alfonso cuarón children of
men and gonzález iñárritu 21 rams and
dhaval mexican film has joined a limited
court of what might be considered
transnational cinemas that arguable
includes Brazil China Argentina and
India but a new age of gold then cinema
has taken shape and attention has
focused on whatever the time-worn visual
and narrative styles of the national
Jenner has given way to more
transnational approach and feel although
they Golden Age broadly dating from
1930's today late 50s was never a
medically national as it often
represented subsequent transnational
cultural flows at economic globalization
have made this idea of contemporary film
fitting national province and holding an
essential specificity oddly
anachronistic these processes do not
only affect how film is produced finance
and disseminated but also the subject
matter themselves and their cinematic
treatment Mexico has itself become
significantly more transnational more
Lesko Tim news with the emergence of
new new cinema and particularly notable
features has been the emergence of
transnational spaces within Mexican
cities typifies by the mega-project
exports own smalls and historic downtown
in this work we use film or rather
cinematic space as a tool with which to
analyze contemporary Mexico City the
locale for the majority of new cinema
the cinematic treatment of cities it's
an important medium for how audiences
and academics in managing the urban
experience two key points are the pin
this work first considering the
contemporary city for film exposes a
methodological dilemma not adequately
address in urban studies if as many
academic studies have assumed
representations of place are produced by
legitimate social relations of power and
hence reflect and form identifiable a
view ideologies then film is an
important component of our ideas of
place yet both film itself and political
economy of the city have become more
global or transnational so that the neat
idea of representations are produced of
a spill of a place from a place breaks
down transnational cinemas
representations of Mexico City does not
simply rely on how cinema sees the city
but also how the city sees itself being
formed international processes the
representations of Mexico City therefore
our boat responds to different mores in
film and of shift of the form of and the
idea of the city second as the cinema
and the city have the Conn
transnationals so how films are seen
reflects a transnational eye on the city
the audience is no longer a national or
regional one nor it's an international
one that has the same acceptance of
national probes or storyline or
portrayals as Garcia and Lena has
suggested the film industry is
implicated in the production of the
local through the transnational
processes that require material
retail territorially station sir the
folkloric is advanced attenuated and
made generic through transnational
manifestations and the importers of
embedded and local becomes more about
become more important but the
transnational idea of mexico city is far
less likely to be dead of the folkloric
mexico of valientes mattress and
indigenous woman caught up in an
emotionally charged melodramas set
against backdrops of colonial buildings
or perhaps the modern city the
transnational visions of the local has
changed and it's likely to understand
Mexico and Mexico City as a space of
violence drug poverty with congested and
polluted cities industrial and the
industrialized landscapes as well as a
space of chick elites and consumption
cinema has important form this vision
the cinematic representation of the city
has provided its own account independent
of the city as it might really be or
even how others imagine it in the
process of making and watching film
wholly new understands of the city and
of the city are produced as such film
can be stabilized urban meanings through
the formation of others the work is
organizing three sections in the first
we are going to outline the re-emergence
of Mexico film industry today to a
leading position in translational cinema
we briefly outline how transnational
cinema suggests a number of different
registers the organization of the
industry their relation with diasporic
audiences and most important the
reworking of a national aesthetic style
for international consumption in this
second we discuss how the city has been
treated in the Golden Age cinema of the
40s and 50s and set of key drops of
representation the third third section
analyzes a number of contemporary films
in part to follow these drops but also
to identify new signs are related these
to the changing instructor from Mexico
City our aim is to
see there in what way the cinematic
representation relate to transnational
views of the city film production of
five features length films in 60 in 1926
and 38 in 1941 by Nate and nineteen
fifty Mexican students were releasing
over 120 fields the National is cinema
of the 30s that attempted to capture the
spirit of post-revolutionary age to the
nuevo cine of the 60s created important
cultural icons that is still running in
popular culture as in the case of
Cantinflas bedroom fun take hoorka
neglected marius alexander lord zedd
real both film exported and constructed
at home created a national identity with
repeated representations of the patent
girl the hero HR character and the fated
prostitute becoming synonymous with
mexican film and the national character
nevertheless the majority of films
producing this time were partially
financed by the Banco Nacional
cinematography code and later by the
Mexican film institute which issued its
financial influence and co-production in
a climate of political censorship to
limit cinema as an outlet for criticism
a combination of a state control and
economic austerity mark the areas as
perhaps the last dynamic era in Mexican
film despite the breakthrough of canoga
park chocolatte 92 the economic crisis
of 94 to 96 first production to fall to
less than 10 films and domestic cinema
and audiences members continued to drop
from the late night is however Mexican
film production was about to enter a new
new golden an age films such as sexo
pudor lagrimas la ley del hielo days and
todo poder appear to critically
acclaimed even if they remain unknown to
large domestic and Latin American
audiences a subsequent branch of films
however confirm Mexican films too as a
box of x gold among these groups we have
amores perros y tu mama tambien de la
calle
I naclo anti LED light these films were
nominated for and won a house of
international awards both in the US and
Europe a range of factors probably
explained the shift the relation of
financial controls and fertilization of
the banking system coincide with the
emergence of emergence of a small
private production companies many of
which had gained technical expertise in
advertising and personally trained
abroad these private production and
distribution companies unconverted by
the overheads of the larger studios as
well versed in the demands of commercial
cinema were attracted countries for
financial support from Phil company
banks and governments in Spain France
and the UK by 2000 the majority of
Mexico's best-known films are
predominantly financed privately and
mostly from abroad although the domestic
cinema marketing makes it in Mexico has
responded to the renaissance of
production and being Mexico the fifth
largest market in the world most films
on show under international and mostly
us blockbusters indeed during the night
is the domestic cinema market
restructure with a closure of many small
independent houses and large multiplex
chains have appeared the vast majority
of Mexican films are neither distributed
within or without of Mexico to any
considerable degree domestic output
represents only about ten percent of
films distributed mostly with showed a
heart full of cinemas and our
University's campus our film festivals
filmmakers and bloggers however are
aware of the potential of Mexico as a
global brand in the key US market a new
new cinema has smooth Mexican films out
of the niche catering to Spanish
speaking audiences or our taxes crowd
and competing with films from Brazil
India turkey or China to the main screen
complexes the diasporic mexican and
global audiences hold a complex image in
the imagination of what mexican means as
a cinematic space appreciation of the
golden age
and melodrama to a niche has acquired
new audiences and meanings through the
internet giving such chapters as Maria
Felix and Elora dollars a video post
mortem carriers through the
representations of Mexico and Mexicans
remains highly contentious convenient
order to which Hollywood films have
easily supply of bodies in the guise of
that dictators lazy peasants and more
recently drug and child traffickers
kidnappers and corrupt politicians as
soon as shows Hollywood's representation
of our barbaric sexual light and peace
big tourist Mexico has been long time an
audience to both the Mexican government
and Mexicans in the u.s. concerned with
how the patria was represented little
critique emerged however of how Mexico
represented itself that could not be
controlled through censorship the new
age of God the new golden age
represented a set of films through which
mexican might represent itself a
different mexico from database 40 to 50
coming to terms with the aftermath of
revolution in the street change and
organization how would the films of
translational cinema represent a
neoliberal ultras national mexico in
particular how would it communicate
ideas of the mexican city we did offer
new insights construct original
narratives convey different outlooks
through cinematic technique or rely on
reinventing established drops with a
contemporary twist Mexico City at the
time of the 40s and 50s Golden Age of
Mexican cinema already had a population
of over three million people and was
undergoing rapid organ growth and
industrial change the small workshops
and large factors of the city score and
the north to the north were being
overtaken by industrial parts the fabric
of the colonial and 19th century city
was being extended with projects servers
that tournaments base in davis remained
and we're now added to purpose building
apartment blocks and the ciudad perdida
mostly in areas close to industry and
major infrastructure this were they can
counter points to the audience to the
eldership modernist architecture of
Mario pani invisible dragon adorned with
the syncretic three signs of Carlos
Meredith evita pozzi chaos and 10 Gorman
and are combined by large-scale public
works programs especially in roads
health and education films such as a
skinny behind maldita to death a
nosotros los pobres scrutinized the
directions and quality of
industrialization state urban project
and consumer culture and often pitch the
indigenous migrant as a counter position
to the Arabah irritate urbanite so not
all film could be classified as
melodrama the use of long emotional
silences or inner thoughts and tensions
communicated through songs where as much
a figure of the urban films as to the
world rural so sorry I have to skip a
part of the paper so going and I'm going
to skip apart and go to the revisited
cinematic city a civil era has observed
Mexican cinema has been a great mirror
of the city in which the films of the
past 30 years have captured all the
transformations of the city and its
inhabitants their emotions and their
dreams and Joyce a kitten invent helping
with the changing nature of the city
during the process of neoliberal is a
shin and globalization in solo con tu
pareja alfonso cuarón explores Mexico
City at the height of the Salinas
neoliberal reforms and without knowing
it to the coast of the NAFTA and the
separatists responds the main
protagonists are middle class and
professional hips sexually liberated and
extreme confidence the film is set near
to downtown with the city represented as
an exciting creative and vibrant space
cuarón city is now over 20 million
people coming to terms with organization
is no longer a realistic motive the
challenge has become
on to term to come to terms with
globalization and social relations
admits cosmopolitanism amores perros
offers a similar reprise of
neoliberalism and in particular of the
new liberal city Polanski claims that
neoliberalism is not directly reflected
by the film a point we disagree with the
viewer is asked to make numerous
references to the past a central
character achieve 0 is a former
revolutionary who gave up his
middle-class lifestyle and family for a
set of values a decision he now bitterly
regret and as his services as an
assassin the idea of that part have been
replaced by individualistic and
mercenary activity in a market economy
of violence yes yet we can observe more
direct references to neoliberalism in
amores perros most obviously in the
career of Elena's valerian the model
whose life is a series of fact aside if
we consider amores perros at NSEL 0 &
latona all three films the director
sunrider offer a generic story that is
embedded with contemporary mexican
society and the city yet in an interview
conducted in two thousand gonzález
iñárritu genera to argue that amores
perros was a very universal story
because it is a very local story I never
really show Mexico City with the film he
says but people who've been there tell
me they could smell mexico city in the
film at one level therefore Mexico City
stairs for what the loose cause and
space whatever a city like any other in
the world not the coastal cities have
the same but because of the similarities
of the urban condition in an interview
Carlos regardez made a similar remark
that geography is unimportant I felt I
could be in the 20 or Africa or whenever
he said the cinematography underscored
that in the end in space whatever
element in the all three films the city
is which visually anonymous in some
important ways in a modest Paris for
example there is no use of buildings
monuments or paintings shots that
indicated mexico city is on which parts
of this or any parts of the city in la
zona a sir
anywhere nest is provided by the
architectural references houses on a
street resemble any recent US server but
also similarities with gated communities
elsewhere in Latin America battaglia
those offer glimpses of a recognizable
city must scenes are shot in palawan
loma and there are settings across since
saturday in the metro and the socal when
the Basilica but something different is
going on there their relation to the
iconographic city service at highlight
the traumas of Carlos the Catholic and
products occur these three films also
show the female characters in recent
will perform more complicated and
certainly more ambivalent roles in la
zona they play moral compass against the
violence of the residents and eventually
the police in a more is the seemingly in
power Talia becomes a pale reflection of
her earlier self after the clock crash
anxious and closing her flat and other
female characters are depicted as weak
and unknowing dominated by the main and
their responsibilities at mothers and
housewives in amer sparrows urban
fragmentation runs in parallel with
social breakdown indeed among the three
fields there is a variable rock gallery
of characters from all levels of mexican
society living dysfunctional lives
states that do not function as they
should and social frictions according to
novato amores perros is an exploration
of how max the white mexican society has
lost our fraternity the contemporary
cinematic treatment of the city still
revolves around the relations of place
and identity drawing upon principal on
Finn and la calle contains claims that
as slow and in predictable dismantling
of the structure which give legibility
to notions of identity and place in the
city coupled with the search of him for
meaning on behalf of the protagonists
which drives them into a dome quest of
lost origins cinematic representation of
cities are not objective accounts
showing how the city really is
and they're careful crafted metal have
undermines their approach as more
immediate and a live presentations of
daily life brother film offers specific
imaginations of the city sometimes
deliberately chosen and conscience
aesthetics and form which particular
meanings can be unpacked and sometimes a
general sense of sight in which is
worked out by the audience's this later
interaction between the film and the
audience's is especially powerful at the
gates of both immediacy and moving image
an opportunity for for reflection we do
not wish to suggest that Mexican new
cinema represent Agenor of its own right
although it is intriguing to consider
the quality of fields as representing a
corpus of work there is no consistency
in the points of foraging or narratives
of the city that represent while most
film pick up on motives in popular
culture and concerned common terms most
notably violent sexual relations and
often insight into contemporary organism
we hesitate to suggest that an emergent
mexican war despite the animal charmer
and feelings of displacement the
breakdown of conventional relations with
others look out of the city the city's
self is shown as a more complex backdrop
and subjects to the movies against the
North static or thrown down and see the
little spaces dark inner cities
illuminated by the flickering neon and
traffic the shimmer of crime Mexico City
is shown for the most part to the world
as an opposite of the image of the and
after room to the ecological Hiroshima
thank you
yes yes vamos algo de Paume sorry let's
mcallen and the transnational meanings
of latvian de guadalupe when I thought
of this I guess her a couple of dangers
and going this late in the conference
the first is that everything's been said
so I'm hoping I can say add to that and
I think that question of religion and
religiosity hasn't been brought up so
that's one kind of addition the other
danger i have is representing the
conference convener so i'm actually
going to ask claddagh thank you so much
for inviting us but also to join me for
the Q&A so this paper actually comes out
of a couple of different projects that
we've been working on and I wanted to
contextualize another project first and
talk kind of arc harking back to some of
what was said yesterday about global
tourism as an active travel for pleasure
a lot of movement and embedded in a
colonial economy at the global scale and
often in terms of decision-making local
communities lose power and also you know
there's not that not too much
accountability and again this idea of
empire unequal exchange well glad and I
were very much working on the idea of
local tourism and another paper in
contrast to kind of global tourism as a
structure to think about a different
form of tourism and I promise I won't do
this irritating scroll the whole time
but first I wanted to think of this idea
of bounded tourism as one that it has a
complex relationship to local
communities and we think of bounded
tourism its corporate owned spaces with
public functions that really capitalize
upon the idea of longing or nostalgia
for homeland and for us in California in
the context of Bless America which I'm
going to be talking about today
increasingly it's impossible to reach
home you have this very difficult
context of the impossibility of return
especially because of the us-mexico
border being increasingly fortified
immigrants being increasingly surveilled
the danger of crossing itself
dehydration deportation sweeps that were
talked about so eloquently yesterday and
a general kind of anti-immigrant
political environment which makes it
very very different for people to to be
mobile and so the idea of being stuck in
a place right so in this sense bless and
may he go in another paper we talked
about as a new form of venture
capitalism that really targets ethnic
market niches and especially
transnational subjects that are bound by
plates so plus and may he go um you know
I'll talk about in a second but it's
it's really a mall and in this paper
instead of focusing on bounded tourism
we really want to talk about
transnational connectivity and how it
happens beyond the sphere of
quantifiable economic and political
arenas to describe some of the
qualitative cultural manifestations of
transnational experience we're really
interested in this idea that of cultural
religiosity but plus I may he go again
as a site of local tourism as a model of
regional and national architecture which
I'll go into and if most of you I guess
are familiar with Los Angeles is located
off the 105 freeway in a community of
eighty-five percent and upwards mexican
population and an important point here
that i think that kind of intersects
with what medium was talking about
yesterday and different that there's a
real desire to appropriate national
companies cafe cannella instead of
starbucks for instance and I kind of
pushed back on Starbucks and other
transnational corporations and
interestingly it's korean-owned okay but
it actually caters to be authentically
Mexican so you don't get a very good
sense of it here but the kind of
construction of the place is very full
architecture a lot of parking in the
center you get a sense of a kind of
Mexico City blass of space and very much
trying to rep
kate certain elements of mexico city
which i'll detail in a second so the
place here is really about kind of this
idea of cultural religiosity which we
describes the forms of expressive
spiritual practices and celebrations
that bridge communal ties between
nations of origins and destination to
create transnational experience the
other concept we really want to think
about is effective connectivity these
are ongoing and persistent forms of
exchange to indicate experience so here
we're really interested in looking at
two sets of celebrations of eating the
weather Lupe and the other lost one of
this want us to talk about what happens
in this place our objectives in the
paper are really to capture
heterogeneity and I'm really interested
in what cuanto of little little the
critical theorist talks about is the
difficulty that we have as social
theorists were challenged by this
expanded social imagination where we
can't really fully incorporate migration
and transnationalism within our horizon
of theory and so that's one aspect of it
but second we want to follow vidoe nice
into 2007 who really describes the ways
that pan Latino identity is constructed
through place and we want to use
ethnographic analysis and spatial
analysis to demonstrate the ways in
which Mexicans use place making
strategies to present and produce a
world of their own so here we're
thinking of blossom Mexico is a really
dense research site or transnational
processes play themselves out in the
vernacular it offers a unique location
from which to really think and discuss
the dynamics of cross-border cultural
activities cross-border imaginaries in a
metropolitan area with an expansive
Latino population finally we're
interested in really expanding and
vitalizing an understanding of cultural
religious practices in space in the
contemporary period so if spaces
themselves of ethnic and cultural
identity have often been theorized by
focusing on very local places such as
the home the street the neighborhood
then it is also because traditionally
these are the concrete place
where ethnic communities are formed and
we're cultural identities maintained its
strongest ties but we want to kind of
debunk this idea and think more
carefully that space culture and
identity are shifting from the kind of
traditional notion of el barrio and
being displaced into privatized
locations but whether or not our
question is whether these private
locations can also serve as kind of semi
public and public spaces that actually
do something to kind of strengthen
social networks so again it's a Korean
own mexican-themed outdoor mall plaza
mexico and it's uh i think important
because a lot of people go there to
celebrate a grito de independencia
mexico independence day thousands of
people went for the 2006 world cup it
Corral's large crowds on Sundays when
patrons stroll around and enjoy regional
Mexican cuisine shop and participate in
blessed programming including Catholic
masses so in a way Catholic Matz's that
it also displaces the function of the
the Catholic Church by having a public
space where people actually worship in
the middle of them all frankly and also
bless you may he co is important because
a lot of the it's the home of hometown
associations like that of Oaxaca Puebla
and Michoacan and these are kind of
community centers that provide key legal
business and cultural services for
immigrants of those regions in Mexico
and a location that nearly all Mexican
government officials and actresses visit
when in Los Angeles for election
campaigning or other business so the
site that people actively cultivate as
part of a transnational political
imaginary as well in fact the owners and
managers of Bless America have worked
very carefully to craft a distinctive
role for blossom Mexico and catering to
Los Angeles Latinos specifically
targeting mexicano immigrants and their
multifold material and effective needs
and desires as one manager briefly
commented to us this is not placita
olvera here the clientele is one hundred
percent TM por ciento Latino so this is
about the ability to really capture the
imagination of the
Latino Diaspora and a primary strategy
of the managers of blossom Akiko has
been to create expand and capture the
clientele through cultural programming
as I mentioned before it's also
important to acknowledge that the forms
of cultural connection are really
structurally facilitated by the
management of the place so if it fills
the kind of mall and economic and market
imperative but we also are interested in
in suggesting i think is you know other
people said yesterday we're not only
wanting to analyze in economic terms
because we think that midst is much of
the richness and significance of
cultural life but we're also interested
in thinking about transnational
persistence and continuities of culture
and celebrations like those that i
mentioned earlier so these are places
where there's both fetishized expression
of religion that spread through
neoliberal capitalism but also retains
some very local and important rich
elements of culture and I want to kind
of build here on Vasquez and and mark
mccart 2003 to argue that religion
really has always provided complex
strategies for conceptualising self
conceptualizing time and space and must
be really taken seriously as an
independent variable and the present and
a fruitful way to really understand this
is all through also through Julian
Holloway's work which offers a vitalized
understanding of the spiritual and
religious practices one that really
accounts for the importance of enchanted
space and holloway suggests that these
are places where secular and religious
dimensions work together in polyphonic
ways and in fact i think the Day of the
Dead is a really important way where
this mall is absolutely transformed by
enchanted space that is people put up
their altars there's all kinds of from
NASA deep we met elders we met shaman
who actually give blessings there and
the mall is literally transformed by
these regional places and
religious expression but you can see how
it becomes a kind of public forum for
events and again this question of
authenticity really comes forward the
managers are very knowledgeable and
consider themselves to be connoisseurs
of Mexican culture in many ways so
they've created all these replicas here
is a Alka villa independencia from
Mexico City and one of our informants
common to it commented to us she was an
elderly woman she said Jeremy Lamb
talaga you know she confused and
actually thought that the angel was
brought from Mexico City so this
creation of both a reproduction of
elements from from Mexico but also you
know where people actually feel that
they can be in their country and that
kind of layered response this is also a
lot of Aztec symbols throughout so the
other los Muertos becomes an important
way in which people come in and actually
do both political work and religious or
spiritual kind of significant work and
it was interesting during much of the
via the most wonderful celebrations that
we also talked with people about the
ways in which they were also using this
to express politics through
anti-immigrant acts and and also to talk
about you know those who had been killed
crossing the border so it becomes this
very complex religious political dynamic
the viewing the weather a little bit
celebration is what we spend most time
on in the paper and I guess what I would
say here is the desire again by the
managers to create something authentic
as manager Christie nagila told us
lebyadkin was actually brought they have
a replica of the vidiian the weather
Lupe and installed in a specific place
and I don't have a picture of it today
but in a specific place in blossom a he
go on December 12 2002 after an
exhaustive study and approval by Mexican
church officials and a blessing ceremony
by father has usado olvidalo the head of
the Mexico City Basilica so the weekend
weather Lupe is people come they give
offerings to her there but then she's
everywhere around the block
so we we have site many sightings of la
virgen de guadalupe her apparition is
literally everywhere and it's also very
much a part of the iconography of the
location and at the same time it's an
opportunity for these regional
associations in an ocean of regional
identity to have a sense of itself and
often also a place for transgenerational
transmission of cultural identity
through the Posadas the seven days
during december 12 how am i doing on
time pretty good okay good um so you
know it's been interesting to do we had
a team of people that we worked with we
did it another fierce ellsworth with
graduate students and one really telling
moment was when I was talking with five
Central Americans one of which was
mexicano about Salvador and what the
Milan and what they call hafiz and
people from mostly in the Pico Union
area and they were describing the way
they'd come to blossom akiko to escape
their vario as a place of security as a
place to actually feel a sense of
cohesion to something some two of them
told me they'd just gotten out of jail
and and I asked well why this place and
they said meet I look at you know I'm
carrying the viewing the weather lupe
have come here to give her things to
honor her but also to cruise girls you
know to hang out as a real kind of
vitalized space for them that they said
they don't feel safe in their video so
this in some ways again replaces the
idea of the video and again the idea of
the beauty and taking care of us she's
good to us and it's important to show up
here and honor her so place becomes this
actual expression of some kind of notion
of kind of contemporary spirituality
so I guess one of our questions is very
much what kinds of identities are
performed here and you know the beauty
in the weather Lupe sits as a national
symbolic that's been hybridized that's
been transnational eyes that becomes a
political emblem that people where not
only on themselves obviously but it's
graffiti and also as a tattoo I think
it's also important to think about it as
how it works in this particular
commercial venue one way that it works
is it's that kind of uncomfortably the
image alongside the white Santa Claus
within the plaza Mexico and as a neon a
kind of consumer image and along like I
said Santa Claus and the elves and so
one could ask is this really an
interesting you know revelation or is it
more part of kind of consumer capitalist
integration of everything that's out
there so that's been one of our
questions so in one since I think the
forms of identity that plaza mexico
makes available could be labeled
essentialist whether either a mexicano
identity is made legible through
nationalist symbols and celebrations or
pan Latino identity is connected through
the marketplace and held relatively
stable by other relational identities
however what really surprised is most in
our interviews what was that despite the
obvious architectural efforts to
recreate Mexican it's in the mall
resulting in a clearly pastiche and
postmodern place almost all of the
patrons asserted to us that Blass Oh
Mexico indeed felt like the homeland a
term that consistently came up in her
field was its quote unquote authenticity
which it was strange to us but it seemed
authentically Mexican to clientele in
its food its Plaza design especially
among the celebration of events such as
Day of the Dead and beating the weather
Lupe so let me see what so really we
wanted to think about this place as
within the contemporary reduction of
public spaces that are available with in
Los Angeles and because of increasing
privatization in the last 20 years and
especially in the city places like the
grove another mall and Hollywood and
Highland shopping malls have really
become the hearts of leisure activities
in the urban metropolis
and in the case of plaza mexico its rise
as a popular destination among and
almost exclusively latino clientele is
due to the marketing of cultural
authenticity producing this place is
linked to traditional mexican heritage
and it becomes then a met about mass
consumer ethnic case and political
orientations but in fact it's it's
interesting again to note the degree to
which is used as a space of
demonstration for example in 2006 during
the anti-immigrant legislation students
who actually walked out of their high
schools congregated here for their
rallies and it's interesting that they
chose this as the site of their
political contestation and there's been
many other instances you know in terms
of both social movements that are
conservative and more progressive and
time minutemen rallies have been here
but there have also been attempts to
actually hold minutemen rallies there in
terms of kind of the questions around
immigrant rights i think we want to
argue that unlike the grove or hollywood
and highland the cultural politics that
emerged are really tied to an inherent
political difference or marginalized
status of immigrants and that these are
expressions become important kind of
cultural artistic elements that
challenge easy notions of mahogany dad
and some displays incorporate critiques
of US government critiques of empire and
racism and really show up in in a lot of
kind of different places I don't have
images to ground that okay so within the
restricted space of consumption blossom
Mexico provides a setting of expanding
possibilities including a mexican-themed
environment that creates a kind of
inspiring background for cultural and
religious ritual and really it's the
perhaps the most important effect of the
expressions are not necessarily distinct
from the many celebrations that occur
around the US but certainly facilitated
by a large scale production of
programming in the mall and as a plus a
visitor anak Guzman said in front of the
Oaxacan altar we come here we put bread
and flowers and treats for our dead to
shore young children what it means to be
from Oaxaca
and that you know really her common
indicates that one of the most salient
aspects of how it facilitates the making
of identity is through again this
intergenerational transmission where
culture becomes an opportunity and a
strategy of maintenance of national and
regional identity so just to move to
closing then these are some other you
know Azteca dance of course so some of
the positive aspects of space for
gathering form of local tourism cultural
space transnational linkages and
revitalized religion and of course
there's more negative aspects as well
you know not clear that any of the
profit is actually going back to the
community or that you know most people
there's no public transportation that
arrives there although that's changing I
think and you know is it just a Mexican
version of the malls that we know the
stereotypical aspects of some of the
kind of besties notions and does it feed
off nostalgia for commercial rather than
social and political ends well I guess
in many ways I would suggest that you
know this is not so much a question of
of assimilation we really want to
rethink these locations as you know
places that facilitate something and to
kind of follow Garcia Khan cleani who
explains that the market can actually
produce heterogeneous outcomes that
actually shape social identities and
identify identification in a positive
direction I think that we found that
that the market itself can feel like
home and it also facilitates something
that sociologists like to talk about as
segmented assimilation to their host
nation where by immigrant selectively
preserved traits from the regional
national cultures while adopting more
mainstream American ones as they deem
appropriate but I'd even extend this to
say that you know on the one hand it
does produce this but it also can
reinforce class and race boundaries and
but at the same time there's a book like
I've said many times there's a perhaps
an opportunity for new kinds of social
action and in increasingly privatized
spaces it's been interesting to find the
ways in which
perhaps this is a place that retains
authenticity in a way that we don't see
another location so that's it okay now
call Maria for him again for her second
paper constructing new geographies the
scent of a mega project and thank you I
hope to do better this time okay and
let's see how it all started where can I
build my mind happen was the question
posed by carlos hank gonzález in
discussing the creation of a space in
mexican in mexico city that would
symbolize global corporate power to the
world the idea syncretic nature of the
question reflects both the reg gente or
major desire for such as in space as
well as the way in which the pet project
was subject to the influences and of
power and of the city's elite the
process of considering various sites for
this mega project led to the selection
of the Santa fagel redstone in order to
build Gonzalez's Manhattan there were a
number of actions taken by different
administrations the consequences of
these factions will be analyzed through
the present world we will argue that the
production of the built environment is
heavily conditioned by narratives of
power not only from the state but from
economic elites as well in the case of
Santa fame we will analyze how maxi-cosi
this government follow the not unusual
approach of undertaking urban
initiatives in all territorial manner by
means of top-down urban planning
consequently the events which occurred
as we will learn where evident and
predictable from the beginning at the
dissociation between plants and
realities come into play alto Rotarian
ISM on the part of the government
inevitably required some negotiation and
agreement with sectors of the civil
society illustrating the degree to which
the implementation of transnational
urbanism is restricted to local
circumstances the main purpose of this
work is to investigate make a project
from a point of view that understand
them
negotiated sites in which people from
diverse sectors of the society actively
appropriate contest influence and
determine the outcome of the a given
mega project which engenders
globalization this work will analyze the
personal narratives of power constructed
by the elites as well as the constraints
presented by particular local
circumstances and the origins were in
the early 1980s
when the side chosen for the Santa Fe
mega project we had an area close to 80
square kilometres and from the beginning
the project was conceived as a
public-private partnership and Manuel
Camacho presented of the city from 88 to
93 claimed to have been the author of
the idea of turning santa thing into an
edge City Santa Fe is one of the few
areas in the city where development
started with a master plan it can be
considered a real estate development
orchestrated by the government the
agency in charge was said he chose
metropolitano or so we met in the years
from 80 to 288 Mexico had severe
economic problems the economic crisis
drastically slowed down the development
of all over and mega projects which is
plain white the construction of Santa Fe
came to a virtual stay still standing
during these years however two important
steps for the later development of the
area we're taking the closing of the
garbage dump and the building of the
freeway that connected two of the city's
avenues constituents and reformer with
the freeway to Toluca the presidential
promise of president carlos salinas de
gortari what to transform Mexico into a
first-world nation he decided to further
liberalize a country's economy by
negotiating NAFTA and Mexico City needed
at the a transfer measure that will
reflect its highly sought first world
status liberal reforms in government
triggered real estate investment which
in turn favor conditions for the
continued development of Santa Fe the
project as ambition follow the global
trend set by urban mega projects in such
cities as Paris or London witla defense
or Docklands respectively for commercial
area can take having a large scale
project showed of his capacity to waste
their position mexico city in turn in
the international arena was of utmost
importance as it contributed to building
a platform for his presidential
aspirations they will known architect
ricardo legarreta intolerable
Leon were commissioned to develop the
master plan it is relevant to note that
while they were not experts in urban
planning they were the most highly
regarded architects of the time since
the idea of Santa Fe was to build a
managed city the architects were sent to
century city in California seeking a
clear vision of the kind of urban model
they were being asked to develop while
serving net sales for brochure described
the master plan as their detail and
highlighted a rigid zoning policy
oriented to optimum land usage the
reality was that the architects deliver
a highly a schematic plan that was
neither totally detailed not finish the
master plan has master plan has been
severely criticized seen is it did not
adhere to Mexican customs for
utilization of urban space the initial
master plan failed to be integrated into
the existing urban fabric from the first
drawings an attempt was made to create a
particular urban environment totally
separated from the rest of the city
zoning of the area was very specific
with little mix use which resulted in an
automobile dependent urban plan Santa
first concept is one of the is a one of
an urban enclaves long wide avenues from
lonely children McNally characterizing
the urban grid only the Mexico to look a
freeway which divides the product into
two crosses over the mega project at a
higher terrain level with no access to
or from the area making it impossible to
access the mega project from transversal
streets all other longitudinal streets
are dead ends or call our circular
streets transversal streets are few
while many are cul de sacs or private
roads resulting in a disarticulated
urban grid that promotes gated
communities with dedicated streets which
vs. further reinforces the idea of an
urban enclaves in 1989 with the first
master plan finish serving meds began
commercializing the land and the traffic
in attracting investment to the area
became imperative hence models of the
side were constructed to prevail upon
developers to invest in Santa Fe and
government officials and bark on
emissions
contract contact transnational
corporations along with a real estate
developers the government successfully
persuaded several investors who came on
board and began constructing the first
of his buildings in 92 during the
economic boom that was generated by the
neoliberal reforms implemented by Selena
I in a climate of high optimism and with
the proxy presidential promise of
turning Mexico into a first world
country that seemed to be coming true so
nearly third of the product in existence
to the inside of it were initiating
during this time the construction of the
first office building began despite not
having building permits or licenses due
to the lack of infrastructure to lack of
infrastructure and public services
during the first years the visiting
operated will I relied on when I
generator to supply electricity mobile
my mobile phones were used in place of
land land and water supplies was done by
water drunk-dial thanks from 1993
according to various developers while
invested in Santa Fe continues with more
than 20 offers building being built the
government seized allocating resources
to the needed infrastructure and what
was heinous in next systems began to
deteriorate when new in fracture in free
structure was built it was a very low
quality and several as aspects of the
project were not completed the dreams
and desires for a low global city is
started to collide with local realities
the master plans modern sketches and
descriptions of the mega project we're
totally disconnected from the reality of
what actually happened on the ground
illustrating that inserting a foreign
urban model was not enough to produce a
first-world enclaves in Mexico City even
if the master plan imitated an American
edge City at implementation local
conditions transform their intended
outcome local politics and deeply deeply
embedded corruption in the government
influence the build environment that was
supposed to embody
a global city the difference between the
government's promises and capacities
were not evident until Santa Fe cease to
be the major priority and deeper level
of corruption angel another significant
problem in the area is the lack of
access to proper access roads they may
Navin UN's to access the site do not
have enough capacity to provide a smog
it's a smooth access resulting in
serious traffic on check congestion
several times a day even with all these
setbacks by 2006 the plots of the mega
project were almost fully sold
approximately 160 corporations have
their offices in Santa Fe such as
chrysler hewlett-packard ericsson
citibank IBM general electric etc since
the objectives of this development was
to promote local investment through the
creation of a wide range fringing
project that would not only help
transnational companies but also an
american-style shopping mall with
services such as cafes restaurants and
along with private schools and
universities hospitals high-end gated
communities and apartment buildings and
today most corporate office buildings
housing projects and shopping centers
are being designed by transnational
firms and it is important to think of
Santa fame as cute and as a part of a
longer history of the OTF involvement of
political figures and bureaucrats in
urban development and landmark project
in Mexico City several politicians
claimed to be the authors of the idea of
the development of Santa Fe blaming
previous or subsequent administration
for Santa Fe's shortcomings illustrating
a lack of accountability distinctive to
the Mexican political system given the
extent to which Santa Fe is publicly
regarded as an organ failure none of the
architects involving the design of the
master plan wants to be associated with
a mega project today the use of lark is
a large-scale urban projects in order to
tell the story of the nation to the
global community is by no means new or
exclusive to make
the city what has changed throughout
history is the conception of modernity
and how to achieve it mega project are
only the most recent phenomena in a
longer history in which politicians
frequently built large and visible
projects in order to show commitment to
national building and a rating not only
the nation pass but its future by
reordering the cityscape even if Santa
Fe was created with the intention of
being at first world including the city
this gold was impossible to achieve
since their existing conditions of for
its development seriously influenced the
ways in which blueprints materialize and
the resulting outcomes were determined
mexico city's government throughout most
of the 20th century have instituted
urban initiatives in an authoritarian
fashion by means of top-down top
download one planning therefore it can
be seen in the case of Santa Fe the
city's government follow the same
approach both in the development of the
master plan and in their ways it was
carried out the resulting stories
unfortunately entirely predictable since
the dis connections between plants and
realities are an ongoing narrative of
mexico city's urban history at the
moment in which the mega project was the
priority for de la gente or major this
entity had enough power to guarantee the
smooth development of Santa Fe however
as soon as the priorities were directed
somewhere else corruption became the
primary power that drove the engine of
development the poor infrastructure
resulting from fraudulent maneuvers
became the main concern of investors who
anticipated I'll drop in their assets
value given the lack of accountability
and the power both live by the agencies
of the various governments the investors
developers and residents of Santa Fe
took the situation in there to their own
hand the fulfillment of the interests of
this economic elite and leading to
further privatization and segregation of
Santa Fe but no without contestation
from for excluded social groups these
analyses thanks to shed light on the
dynamics that shape the intrapreneurial
city layer learning from mistaken
choices is imperative mega projects have
to often have obtained proven to be the
result of us here
of erroneous decisions rather than
seeing the outcomes as an accidental or
intended we must find and understand
what is missing in the blueprint and
their implementation in the hope for
learning of learning from them therefore
the argument prevails that failing to
fully understand the complexities of the
local and the local being practices and
actors the global will always be
unintended thank you and now for our
last panelist here in this session
meditate is a Vasquez Castillo
presenting the u.s. Latin American city
and the Latin American USCG the case of
Mexico City and Los Angeles
thank you I have to tell you that I
started this research because some from
mexico city originally and I live in LA
so I go back and forth and through the
years what I've been noticing is all
these changes in both cities and that's
why the title is armed the US Latin
American city and a Latin American US
city and the cases of Mexico City an LA
those were person changes ya know I make
a gallows nice richness okay I also
would like to think or to ask you to
think in the United States not only in
terms of a lake but in terms of all the
United States and how different states
have different Latin American
populations like if we could place those
populations in the map you could see
that in a way not only a label the
entire United States are representing
different populations different Latin
American populations like for example
Florida Cubans Colombians a chance ain't
California mexican and central americans
I'm just mentioning some of them and
Massachusetts Brazilian Senor Diaz
people from Central America and the
Caribbean and evidently in New York and
I don't have to mention more other
states but I want you to visualize the
United States and the different Latin
American groups that have gone through
time to all these places and I think
that um and a four to understand these
friends historically and in academia any
policy has been not only in lesser
recently a few years ago it has been
created the US Latino track in latin
american studies but also they will seem
two thousand and
aid the conferencing cancer the nest
america in the united states and
actually i didn't put there there are
many other conferences to but in october
of last year the diverse suburb that
also was trying took that took place in
Hofstra University and that try to bring
this question that is not only in cities
but it's also happening in the suburbs
and probably it's happening at some of
you I think that in the case of some of
the papers here in the case of rural
areas in towns and evidently thank you
for to Clara for organizing the
transnational Latin American isms that
is yet another effort to try to
understand these processes and open the
conversation and more than anything else
the thinking about it like it's
something that we're doing a or starting
to do oh no let me see so what I'm going
to do oh how i started my presentation
or my thinking it was to do type things
like okay how the production of open
space in Latin American citizen me in US
cities has taken place how the influence
of the United States in Latin American
cities has been and vice versa and what
is this thing what is this concept of
Latin ization of LA our the
Americanization of Mexico City and what
that means for Al and capital labor an
urban planning and then I'm going to try
to draw some conclusions let me tell you
of the legislation of LA if the concept
that was developed by my Davies Victor
by a Rudy Torres and it came out a
little bit before the two thousand
sensors but mostly when this bog refer
frame was showing all over the United
States his presentation about the
letting
session of the United States with very
fancy maps showing how the Latino
population was going even to areas that
it was not a common destination and that
it had become a common destination in
terms of the Americanization of Mexico
City I don't know if that's really a
time had people asking any disability
Americanization of Mexico City I think
that the scores are probably you can
also help me too we think about this is
like the dispersed has been mostly in
how Latin American cities have a door
debt either planning ideas have adopted
urban form that changed through time and
historically that organ form evidently
I'm talking about the Americanization
because of the urban form or the
homogenization of these of these are
enemy so my objectives was like okay
wine I was mexico city looking how we
think more Americanized y los Los
Angeles was looking more Latino but not
on only dad every time I went to Mexico
I was just thinking oh my god like how
come Chicanos in LA I really striving to
keep the culture or to recreate it and
how come Mexicans in Mexico City are
following the opposite friend what is
happening you know and what elements are
influencing the production of or
webspace image metropolitan area and
were these processes like I was in like
how one process was going probably to be
more Americanized and the other one to
be more Mexican what do these processes
mean what are these contradictory
processes or are they closely inter
green put the meaning of these processes
so I work with some hypotheses and I
change my hypothesis every time like
trying to grass and trying to understand
or what what is happening I come from a
background of political economic so for
me capital labour and it's very
important the same as planned and the
same as urban planning ideas salmon or
rabbit land air tube suppose the Quentin
for me that was very important to see
what was happening with capital with
investment for what's going what was
happening with labor what's happening
with the land you know and what's
happening with the diffusion or not
about Pam planning ideas the other
hypothesis was was the Latin ization of
US cities an indicator of this latin
america in the united states and if the
Americanization of Latino of Latin
American cities was an evidence of the
continuous presence of us in Latin
America other hypothesis was there is
resistance of the United States to
become Latin American eyes and seemingly
a consent of Latin American cities to
become more Americanized
probably i don't need to go through all
the scores of how different urban
planners or run sociologies or organized
have conceptualized the production of
urban space in Latin American cities
what it was interesting for me it was
more of different civilizations palm
from outside latin america and in Latin
America we have just case by case study
but it's not like we have gotten
together and we have said it's like okay
this is the generalization abroad me
because not possible but probably
something that we need to think but
regularly what we have is that people
use all the conceptualization of our
Latin American cities are in terms of
how also is conceptualized the famous
thirlwall city like the rural-urban
migration the irregular settlements
informal have seen the lack of urban
services the unplanned urban growth you
form a labor for social movements and
then for Mexico it seems that um that
was also the case it was a study from
below from the grassroots social
movements thrall of informal settlements
and it was interesting for me like now
we see all these elements of Santa Fe
for example in the case that was
mentioned that the middle and upper
income housing Mexico is being built no
but regularly have there are very few
studies of how these two processes
happen at the same time what's happening
point are Santa Fe has been built and
what happened with the people that was
there before where do they go you know
so what's the process there you know and
where and how this place has been
allocated also for economic and
commercial activities and what that
it's also for the city what led to the
geographic distribution in the sea for
me it was interesting to see the role of
Latin America in the American cities I
teach this class on the growth and
development of cities for me it was
interesting to see that arm many of my
students are don't know the role of
immigrants in the production of cities
and it was interesting on top when I
took them to feel free to downtown LA
because you would imagine that a
students that go there because they live
in LA they have been into downtown LA
well wrong like they have not been in
Duncan la many of them and consequently
they don't know that there's a plaza
very few of them know about la placita
olvera and I'm not talking about a
primary school this is a state-owned
school so for me it was interesting to
see how also the form of the city had to
do we have students learn about American
cities and in this case about LA so for
me it was important to talk about the
production of of urban space but to talk
about from the point of view of also how
immigrants have a build the city and the
segregationist segregationist measures
that have on healing is specifically
segregated them you know restrictive
covenants with restrictions redlining
all these elements that segregated the
african-american communities in other
cities in the united states have a
specificity in LA what is happening
um what I found is that most of the
research is focused on Orbis space for
above the capital but you don't see in
the history overlay except in that
literature and that work that is done
either by historian or don't inch kind
of stories about the world of immigrant
communities and specifically in this
case about the world of Mexican
communities so the displacement and
disposition that took place in LA you
know is not really visible you know
because the role of these communities is
not part of history evidently the
indigenous and Mexican history survey
layer seldom mentioned you know one of
the cases that is very documented
probably you know is the case of Chavez
Ravine that it was the case of how this
Mexican community that was this place so
that they could build the torture
stadium but aside from that other
displacements are not so well known so
definitely a transnational research
agenda on production of our space that
is taking in to apply into into
consideration the transnational capital
the transnational migration the planning
ideas the transnational spaces and the
impact on the villain environment of
Mexico City and Annalee it's important
for any think that here there's a
consideration that I i would like to
mention let me see oh excuse me I'm
passing it I am NOT bus in my
and and then that one important thing
for me is history definitely for I
consider that waves of polling stations
are important in mexico city in LA hum
mexico city was part of the same
territory how inlaid was part of the
same territory and what that means you
know evidently i'm not going to focus on
much and spanish the wave of
colonization spanish but it's
interesting how some of the replication
of spaces in LA supposedly chickens
basted look very much like a Spanish
architecture or Spanish or perform but
what else I think that we need to think
about you know there's a new wave of if
not the colonization definitely a strong
influence of us into the organ form and
into the displacement of Mexico or
Mexican some because of that I'm going
to talk about the world of NAFTA when we
talk about immigrants Mexican immigrants
in the United States and
transnationalism other place and their
culture whatever it seems kind of a
celebration and that's fine but I think
that also we need to see at the
structural process the bear taking place
and one of them is that this population
left in many cases because they didn't
have jobs or because they were displaced
from belen the worst and land the water
land reform before at the beginning of
the 19th was during the nineteen twenty
something after the mexican revolution
but then when enough that was passed
there was all this economic
restructuring that change the land law
and if that line law before and after
care populations in place but after
enough that they could sell the land it
was away or it opened the door for
privatization of land and people
migrated before and after there was
still you know of
so this bland privatization was not
there there was a whole area of the
influence in urban form in places like
you dad SAT led i'm going to show you a
picture so that's atelier in two places
to suburban place el pedregal de san
angelo that is one of the most expensive
areas in in what not now now it's Santa
Fe you know were in Mexico City last
normal that is very close to Mexico City
to do something and actually they
connected right because now we are
connected to the most the most expensive
area and pedi sure but that was before
but after think what we have is the case
than Maria incorrect presented that is
home the Santa Fe the place and related
to that it was changed that the plaza
loreto if these factory that was
converted and that now you go and we you
don't know the history of what that in
distress place used to be walmart and
actually two weeks ago there was this
huge announcement from just a minute
okay from other the Mexican government
that said that there was going to be a
huge investment probably to build with
115 walmart so you could imagine the
impact that that's going to have in
Mexico im mean like american city the
starbucks everywhere you know 7-eleven
and what is now that historic for what
you used to see the drugstores or the
newer stores of whatever you see the XO
oh honey free message you know
everywhere you know so definitely when
you vote to make sex ed and even when
you go to the downtown for what you see
each how much initiation or app
Americanization of mexico city evidently
that has seen an impact on culture and
practice it i'm going to show you into
me
is that I have the pictures and then I'm
going to leave everything else for the
discussions the sound not going to have
time this is your dad certainly take and
I think that it was important when
somebody was mentioned that is not only
CDs but these was the soap you know this
was before NAFTA it was started building
probably in the late 50s you know and
but it was falling in place in the 1970s
you know the suburban area this is Paris
or oh I'm sorry I'm doing it with like I
cannot see this way okay this is Paris
or this is one of the first of all I
think that the first more in the
southern part of Mexico City and
evidently in the most recent cases the
case that I was presented my money in
the case of Santa Fe this commercial and
housing district and you see not only
the egg solo and the walmart and the
McDonald's or whatever but you see
starbucks everywhere I'm here is like in
one community people were protesting you
know one of the walmarts actually
probably you know about this famous case
but walmart build next to TT gotten that
is one of the most famous anthropology
well hands of illogical areas and there
was a huge protest you know so i want
about this because i want to go to the
photographs of LA here you have class
oil magnate chi that is kind of the for
those of you who have been in la know
like it is like that there's a plaza
mariachi is gonna play there if the like
kind of your equivalent of Garibaldi the
caravel the plaza and actually um where
no was mentioned that there was no
public transportation they are trying to
commercialize this area there's now a
new metro station that goes to la plaza
del mariachi and
connect with the rest of highly plaza
Mexico actually it's very hard you know
if you are in the least very hard to go
by public transportation but if you
walked in minutes there's a metro
station that goes to plus a message you
know but many most people most people
drive you know pleasant make it was an
interesting case I definitely agree with
must say about plaza Mexico when I went
there I had the feeling that I was in
Las Vegas for Mexican you know they was
like oh my god this is you know like
when you're going to la Vega you know
any has like a team that's how I fell is
like on this kind of this thing life for
Mexicans right and evidently you see all
this recreation the even hot punch
phobia there and they I think that they
may have someone like us a burst of
Benito Juarez and anyway but also
there's a very interesting process song
first national murali something related
to culture you know what just have a
minute you have like these um
contestation in what's going to be
preserved in LA and what is happening is
that many of the area's produced by the
Chicano Latino community are you raised
in a way what I say is like this hard
life immigrant the spaces that also have
an immigrant meaning probably a
temporary life because they are not
reserved and they are erased this is a
different case this America tropical
this is a very famous mural by cicadas
that was kind of rescue and it was cover
when it was persuaded because it
depicted an indigenous person crucified
by imperialism and this was painted
right there in the plaza the cycle is
that is la placita olvera no MacArthur
Park that I think that Gerardo here has
a very interesting work on that this is
during the
immigrant demonstrations bless my car to
some say that it was like the
chapultepec of la that chop to the
biggest domain of the main apart and
then you have the south central farm
there is kind of the presentational
agricultural space no i neva dental it
says aqui estamos indo NOS vamos and
they did a left but they the police
arrived and displays them and then tells
you what's happening with production of
these spaces in LA and that then they
are left and I'm then i use want to you
to see in taking up a dispersive Mexico
City Emily about tap it down you know
definitely Santa Fe another mega project
are like the recipient of capital they
are spaces of the location of capital
while you have here in LA the location
of Labor and the productions of the
spaces of labor of immigrant immigrant
spaces I have some other arm slides but
I'm going to leave that thing
ok I would like to call the other
panelists to sit down so that we can
start our session discussion and
follow-on into the final discussion
it is
thank you for your presentation um I was
very intrigued in why Clara invited me
to moderate this section I'm not Mexican
I don't study Mexico I thought it was
very out Diocese of her to say come come
and come and have a look come and talk
with us and as I trust Clara and I know
she's a very serious academic I thought
she must know what she's doing so and it
was very very interesting to have read
the group of four papers on mexico city
basically or the relationship of mexico
city with the US and the
transnationalism implied in this that i
thought it would get gave me a broader
interpretation of what we can understand
by transnationalism and transnational
American Latin American ISM and what I
have seen in the group of panels since
yesterday is that what we have is a
colorful cloth with different threads
which can go through gender and race
which was yesterday morning or afternoon
housing planning architecture art the
production of space remittances the
changing colors and the changing colors
of art how cities change with the
changing colors transnational dense
heterogeneous cities and how the dual
impact of Latin America's in the US
latin america's in spain and how this is
building another color or another cloth
for the world the four papers which were
presented specifically in the session
gives us a very interesting picture of
mexico and mexico city or what we can
call of mexican isms it's a broad
interpretation of mexican culture
through diverse lenses internal and
external cinema and shopping malls in LA
politics of space and geographical
imagination in the
of cities the first paper mexican cities
which was written by garrett jones and
moreno kahan kho discusses a matrix of
questions related to the construction of
images and imaginaries of mexico and
mexico city through cinema what is
filmed where how and financed by whom
all sum up to the debate on visions and
revisions of mexico and mexico city
throughout the past century and maybe
for the future i read the paper
recognizing names the lord is no Hugh
famous throughout all of Latin America
punch EFA's which I remember early
childhood which was already old man and
at the same time I also read the paper
with a little notebook by my side
writing down names of new films I should
see and I haven't seen and recognizing
which was most fascinating patterns of
production of cinema which are at least
in brazil the brazilian cinema are
almost the same which are the cinema
directed by designers and publicity and
the way in which they sell the images
which in many times are images of
nowhere and st. prouder brazil which is
a famous about their Silas the cinema is
that depiction you do not recognize any
place even though all the landscape
images are from Brazil but he does not
depict a brazil and i understand that
the discussion throughout the paper has
very much this this accent on it the
second paper on plaza mexico honor and
la malle written by Macarena gomez
bodies and clara gaza ban discusses how
culture reestablishes itself in a
privatized environment a shopping mall
where the creation management of private
places creates possibilities of
heterogeneous ways in which people
experienced woman in transnational
settings the privatization of public
spaces fear of home security in a city
dispersed geographically as la gives
rise to an interesting phenomena of
private public production of space
in transnational setting in which
religious manifestation occurs in midst
of consumerism transforming even if
moment aeneus ly a consumer location
into an enchanted space as the authors
depicts plaza mexico with all the
strangeness involved korean-owned
mathematic mall fulfills an important
gap in Latino cultural life in LA
bringing into light the growing trend
this is their there they're afraid the
growing trend of displacing these events
from the public realm and replacing them
in private vendors indicating and
tendency of all type of urban
manifestation being a Latino beard even
American of not happening anymore in
public spaces in the US the plaza mexico
is a point in a much bigger iceberg of
what is becoming of public space in
urban environment in the US the third
paper sent up a mega project by Maria
Mourinho kahan kho depicts the long
political process of producing now
liberal space in Mexico the paper inter
wines which she didn't show a lot in the
discussion but was very interesting in
the paper personal politics with
national and international politics on
the financing and eventually producing
now liberal spaces in order for the
country to be competitive and the city
to be competitive it results it also
shows that these processes are long and
changed characteristics as economic
environment changes and how the building
of now liberal spaces is not homogeneous
ly globally but that different forms of
globalization's are produced locally one
that is unique because it integrates the
unavoidable local circumstances with the
global aspirations this paper leads my
head to explore the impacts of little
Manhattan's throughout Latin America the
fourth and last paper presented and
written by Phidias la Vasquez shows us a
double-handed influence of Latin America
US cities and which points to a possible
new agenda for studies in transnational
Americanisms a multi-layered multiscale
or impact of transnational Latin
American ISM on Latin America and in the
u.s. u.s. is more and more bilingual I
always like to remember that when we
arrived here my son like six months ago
he didn't speak English he didn't speak
Spanish now speaks English and Spanish
you do not survive in most of the US
cities if you don't speak Spanish you
can you will only you will only feel
half of the city but if you want to
understand the multi layer of the city
you have to speak Spanish for which of
us and the the idea of this more
bilingual multicultural environment in
which being in the way in the u.s. puts
us in front and having the profession
most of us have as academics that we
think things out now we must ask
ourselves and that's my question and
what I would like to hear what are the
new themes and new research
methodologies that we could build new
and innovative agenda for Latin American
Studies in the u.s. because Latin
American study Brazilian studies have
been through the US Academy for a long
time what can we think about as new
proposals of Latin American Muslims in
this jewelle multi-layer multiscale or
perspective in order to make the debate
more opened and have more people
participating i would like to collect a
couple or three more questions and then
i could open it for you guys
i remember when i first started college
in 1990 at the end of the 90s i remember
going to a conference about my CD and
someone predicting what was going to
happen to colonial keto and i remember
all these academy people telling what is
what's going to happen if we don't do
something well now 11 years later it
happened and the Academy reported all so
I was wondering if all the proposals
that we have listened today and
yesterday have any how does it work for
the accademia to connect with advocacy
projects and to stop what is happening
like are there any of these projects
connected to community-based
organization rather its movements where
does this all this information goes to
influence public policy
yeah I had a question for Clara of my
Corina so I'm very I'm definitely very
interested in how how how immigrants
kind of create a sense of place and this
question could also go to Maria as well
so I think there's this interesting kind
of dip divide in terms of creating kind
of organic spaces for for immigrant
communities or how immigrant communities
go about creating organic spaces whereas
I think what you shown in the blossom
echo example is this almost superimposed
development that that helped create this
the sense of culture so I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit more
about about the distinction there you
know whether this type of development
was more you know to what extent was it
a true kind of mexican development or to
what extent was a controlled from from
other cultural viewpoints then within
that if you could talk a little bit
about the relationships between between
the korean developers in that space and
whether there was any conflict that at
any point
I think that the first question that was
raised about how academia relates to
specific practices it's an important one
than assume that the panel Blatter has
but it's something that I'm very
interested in and I got the kind of a
comment or a question following up of
what hit our judges said if I were to
look at some of the presentations and
maybe plaza mexico less a mexico in
particular from why northern california
progressive berkeley perspective one
could see that as a very kind of typical
case of capital appropriation of
exploitation of immigrants as a way to
expand new forms of profit generation
but the presentation and some of the
other papers suggest other levels of
complexity that raises a number of
questions for me on one hand up is it
really capital appropriating culture and
place or is it people on culture
appropriating a private situation to
make it public and to make it their own
is the question and I don't know if
McCarron and glad I were kind of teasing
us with some of those concepts but I
felt like the same way that the concept
of appropriation went back and forth the
same thing with authentic it almost
seems irrelevant to talk about
immigrants these are people who are
making the place their own and it's hard
for me to comprehend because maybe I
don't relate to all the elements but the
way exchange and retail is mixed with
religion it's mixed with entertainment
it mix with flirting it's a very complex
setting that
seems extremely rich and made me think
that it's probably something more than
just capital appropriation but I'm not
completely clear so if you can elaborate
on that and kind of also what do you see
that as the implications if those kind
of situations were repre- city are we
facing I mean it seems on one hand that
it could be really authentic but not
thinking in terms of immigrants or
Mexicans or and Angelenos but just
people who are our kind of embracing
what they have in front of them and some
kind of collective well I figure we're
Brazilian researchers have any interest
in challenge to handle with which
consists in how to incorporate lading
Americanisms in our research and
questions considering considering we
mainly used to do not consider ourselves
as lead in America almost we used to
consider dating American people not as
as but as others I'd like to hear your
comments about this
well there are so many interesting
questions on the table and I think the
the issue of advocacy work and
relationships with NGOs and activist
organizations so central I mean this
project that glad and I've been doing
grows out of work that we had originally
conceptualized as part of Latino new
urbanism and kind of closely connected
to trying to have Los Angeles in the
larger metropolitan area I think very
carefully through development strategies
that would be more mixed use and all of
the new urbanist practices that you know
we know about and you know as we began
to do that work and work with
politicians etc we realized that that we
were getting away from some of our
initial concerns and that we were more
interested in the kind of vernacular
practice and the way in which not only
people structured their homes but where
people were gathering and these other
two projects the bounded tourism project
in the project and blossom Mexico really
grew out of an organic sense but you
know I think letter should also speak
much more directly because she was very
involved when in Los Angeles with the
south-central farmers and a very very
important experience of political
mobilization and connections between
kind of intellectual quote unquote you
know public intellectual practice and
advocacy work you know in terms of
thinking more carefully about your
question regarding the you know the the
clientele and the managers and how we
can think through some of those things
for us method logically it was actually
quite complex to do some of the work up
less in Mexico we had to get all kinds
of special permission the Korean
investors themselves don't want to in
fact be located with any and any kind of
controversy and maintain a very very low
profile and so there was much discussion
of both where would you work be
published who would know about this we
couldn't get access actually to
interviewing them we only got mid level
access to one of them the managers and
choose very very careful about her
discourse so part of the answer to your
question is is there controversy not
much and in fact because the reason
you know there is a kind of containment
strategy by the management to not
actually divulge their position their
investments etc at the same time there
is this kind of strategic appropriation
right of all kinds of forms of identity
I don't know if glad if you wanted to
address that question more carefully but
maybe should i go to mediums because i
think you're right medium to notice the
the ways in which we don't settle one
way or the other on what kind what what
this amounts up to what is blessed
mexico mount up to and for me I think
that's part of a kind of fear
theoretical practice and I'd love to
hear from Greta but I really think about
like benjamine and this and kind of
moments or ruptures or fragments or
fissures within this you know we could
create a totalizing framework where we
suggested for instance that this is
indeed yet again the flexibility of late
capitalism to incorporate all kinds of
niche markets and and reproduce them but
I think in some ways it was so important
for us to start from practice or moments
and that's why we did so much
ethnography and that's why that kind of
grounded methodology was important to us
to kind of understand well yeah I mean
these are places of cruising you know
these are places of you know where women
talked a lot about using the altar to
educate their you know children that get
away from them in the videos they can
bring them here and you know show them
the bus a fancy toda la muerte or
whatever so it's not there's no totality
here there's so many things happening in
that space precisely and there were
moments where we were absolutely you
know what is the white Santa Claus doing
here with the vidiian and people taking
pictures with the you know the Santa
Claus and so I think that's why it was
important for us to think of a kind of
multi method approach and again to go
back to benjamine that there were
moments where we were literally forced
to stop and the kind of something burst
open like when talking with those young
gang members and they said this is
safety man you know this is safety or it
loudest to kind of break through and
really realize the extent to which in
the last five years I think we've just
seen a total total destruction of Latino
cultural centers I mean I talked about
it very briefly and we talked about in
the paper but the achoo chest self-help
graphics on and on these locations of
independent Latino cultural life that
have a really long genealogy and a long
go back to Chicano moratorium they go
back to really strong political
movements in Los Angeles that in fact
they've been totally dismantled so it
forced us also to encounter the lack of
Independence basis and you know other
spaces opening up noble and other places
but really that this becomes this this
location that what is happening here is
anything happening here that was kind of
our question right so yeah well just to
reinforce a little bit more what
Macarena just said is plus a mexico a
capital and instance of capital
appropriation of culture or vice versa I
think it is neither one or the other and
it's actually both one on the other it's
a lot more complicated that we
envisioned it to be when when we started
our exploration of it and we are not
ready to make it any final judgment on
that because it's evolving before our
eyes we didn't have we didn't have time
to mention for example that now some of
these very same places that milena
referred to yesterday that were that
were selling houses elsewhere in Central
American nations and Mexico etc are now
taking place in class of Mexico as well
they are selling cars they are selling
electronics of all sorts housing
appliances of all sorts so it's
something that continues a reinvention
of itself as our communities become ever
more transnational but they apply
symmetrical really represent
the tragedy of the lack of urbanity in
Los Angeles something that is also the
nature of many other cities in the
States and elsewhere so it is I think
Los Angeles is much better off because
it has plaza Mexico but class and Mexico
is not the ideal condition is just a
band-aid over something that is really
really wrong at a structure level and
that needs to be solved at this
structure level that will bring about
different planning regulations and
practices that will provide for spaces
of community building that are outside
of the preview and management of the
private sector we do not have that this
basis that we're available are
disappearing before our eyes and then
the best things is plaza Mexico that is
appropriated by the community in very
interesting and empowering ways not just
for religious and and musical
celebrations but also for Health Affairs
citizen fairs and things of the sort
that are that are indeed very empowering
and under bill community in a place
where there are very little portunities
to do that elsewhere I want to give a
shot to the question of where do we
where do we go from here in terms of
latin american studies during the break
we were conversing with marcela tovar
and he was proposing that we had to this
Center Latin American Studies from this
area studies that have come to be in in
in our universities here in the States
so we really have to appropriate it back
to all of the different disciplines and
fields that we represent and have this
conversation become a lot more
multi-disciplinary it is
multidisciplinary testing I where are
you the first thing that could save us
and promoters to the next level as we
tackle more complex issues with the
realization of the level
transnationalism that we now have etc
etc so multidisciplinary would be my
first shot then also following on what
Ferren administaff said yesterday we
need a lot more multi-sided ethnography
to make sense of the new realities that
we are facing and to realize and unfold
and unpack their transnationalism and
then we need to work at the
intersections of seems that ian is
asking what are the new themes and I
would rather we don't need new themes we
need to continue deepening our
understandings of the current themes
particularly with the strategy of
working at the intersections of them so
continue working on gender ethnicity
race space our poverty inequality all
the things that interest you but rather
at the interspecies at the liminal
places that have been under explored or
unexplored so far where I think the
opportunity to bear explain the
complexities the interrelations of this
new realities late and I will I will try
to address later and the question about
how is this information going to
influence public policy and at the
University I work for the universidad
autónoma metropolitan Mexico City we
have a lab that is called social
territorial studies lab and surprisingly
they go over the city government has
approached us lately because they need
several they don't know many things that
for us are kind of obvious so we're
being hired to do a project on real
estate another one on security and
myself how Santa fit works at the
metropolitan level so I don't know what
will be the outcome of this but at least
we are being given the opportunity to
try to propose new things so I think
that is a positive the glass again what
I'm going to try to answer it slowly in
terms of bloody snakes are busy clean
wise i think that one question is we
need to wander for those latin latin
america and what is what does this
migration means that when let Americans
move then when they cross the border
that in America ended where the border
is or Latin America expanded and
continuous because of the movement of
people of Labor and with them their
cultural practices even if those spaces
that they are going to be creating in
the New Territories are going to be
either temporary or permanent I think
that another question that could be the
agenda is who's resisting these
processes who's resisting the Latin
ization in different places you know
there's a response not only in the
United States but worldwide you know all
these nativist and nationalist movement
you know in the United States meaning me
the SLS movement in in Italy you know
like the file the emergence of the
fascist groups the new rights everywhere
so what does that mean I mean it's like
it seems that this is happening but
their responses there are responses from
the east come from this forces that are
assisted you know or who's supporting it
or who's consenting and I think that
there are different levels and I think
that one level is the one that you're
observing Brian in front of your eyes
you know and that's the role also of
transnational academics you know and
some of those we have it easy and some
of us we done we call so many different
issues to know of what we study or how
we studied it and who we are you know
and what we have to say and was
resisting what we have to say and who's
resisting us here in your spaces you
know so i would like to ask you back
advocacy to stop but it's happening what
was in your mind when you were asking
that stopping what
you
about macarena sensor to Miriam question
and I was thinking about some of the
things that I mentioned in my dog I I
don't know if you have explored the
articulation theory and how hall and
Chris Berg tried to resolve this problem
of what is it what's before with Stan
what's out in T city again and how that
question becomes completely secondary
and how we can think about those spaces
and collectives as in sandbox and which
have the ability to joint and this joint
different elements and that's why Papa
Noel is is besides la guadalupana right
and we are trying to actually understand
that with it with a complete different
framework that won't allow us to
understand it but I find especially
useful this idea of in symbols that
joint unda joint element deep disparate
elements right that allowed people to
hook and unhook from different spaces
and simultaneously creating different
identities so i think that the
production of difference in those spaces
it's with matters rather than trying to
understand from a more fixed theoretical
point of view those issues so i think
that's that that's trillion lighting and
that's something that anthropology has
brought and I think that God has put it
really really well into these discussion
these two days so yeah maybe a more
mobile thing right in terms of identity
in terms of creating difference etc we
will allow us or help us to start
opening up issues
oh I get up about mediums patheon the
appropriation of space I thought that
the case nasim it was very interesting
because people don't see some concept
for Lacey as a more you know and that's
the thing because if you realize how
malls are used not only in the United
States but worldwide that is these
private property that has a public use
yeah and if we are able to conceptualize
like you know plus a Mexico yeah it's a
replication of all these like a land
hail independencia and punch we are
there the fountain or whatever but
basically you know that's why they said
that it was the theme but basically eats
this private area that is being
appropriated by the people the same as
people in other moons whoa and hung out
there and appropriated it publicly you
know the function is you know although
definitely this has all this gold thread
for notations but people decide to go to
this mall that is plaza mexico and
appropriated not only in terms of public
space but also in terms of pot recipes
but i don't know i just want to respond
to last two comments i mean i think
you're right that it's a definitely in
the case of blossom mexico but i think
about mall space and very quickly
liberalized context like the kind of
fundamentalisms of chile argentina in
you know transition to political
democracy and there the malfunctions
quite differently I would suggest and
obviously it's heterogeneous and we have
to be very contextual about our
responses and historically base but in
many cases like in Ottawa and for
instance there's a case of a mall that
was built right on top of the torture
Center that's also the case in in many
places in Chile where these large
shopping centers will
function as forms of amnesia so the mall
you know and then in upper varios or
whatever so you get rather than this
kind of sedimented public expression you
get forms of kind of amnesia of erasing
the past of things that go in line with
official discourses and official
narratives and the mall becomes a site
of this kind of celebration of economic
globalization that actually has
obliterated all kinds of forms of
historical memory so I think you're
right in and I guess I wanted to point
out it's something else that I think is
very very important in your presentation
and that is the way the function of the
you know eradication of article 27 and
the helo system really served as an you
know mobile mobilizing structural factor
for populations and especially
indigenous peoples to be displaced and
then come to something like Los Angeles
and what we saw was the effects of that
we're all kinds of heterogeneous
indigenous populations from southern
Mexico were actually quite tied to their
identities and this is something I think
I want to have a conversation with you
about further maricela which is I
absolutely love that kind of fluidity
and way in which you are thinking about
the in Samba land house notion of
articulation that that can be
articulated can also be disarticulated
but I just wonder in the case of these
particular structural moments where we
do have this this real you know we do
have Salinas we have not you know the 92
the Sabbath east and 94 etc you know all
of the things that happen in the
disarticulation of a really important
communal land system and then the rer
ticular shin of those identities in the
u.s. that is a very fixed notion of
identity its mobile but what do you I
mean how can we then employ the idea of
ensemble ER do you know what I'm saying
I mean it's it's a genuine question that
I'm struggling with around indigenous
identity its representation in these
global sites but also it
it's rude I don't want to say rooted
cosmopolitanism but it's rootedness you
know what those things seem to be a
little bit do you know what I'm saying
do you have an answer for me yeah well
let's it's a genuine I think we should
okay finish the session because we can
have a quick break and then we're going
to have more general discussion probably
that question won't be answered but you
can talk later but before I finish the
section the session I would like to
thank colada not only for organizing
this interesting seminar but organizing
and keeping a big smile so 50 minutes
break and clatter will come back